e
giscard bongo déjeuner sur les derricks
chirac gardien du littoral peut être
trop tard le point de vue de paul
lefèvre l'intoxication en italie on ne
sait pas la soigner
football une longue saison qui commence
depuis plusieurs semaines le franc
s'enfonce pourquoi léger léger lefranc
dégringole et bizarrement la banque de
france ne le soutient pas le laissant
aux mains des spéculateurs à la bourse
de paris à la fin d'une séance agitée et
nerveuse avec des échanges relativement
peu important la cote du franc par
rapport aux monnaies européennes avaient
encore baisser le dollar a frôlé
aujourd'hui les cinq francs 498
précisément quant au franc suisse
il a dépassé la barre des 2 francs enfin
seul le marquent toujours prospère a peu
progressé il reste aux alentours d'un
franc 96 les mésaventures du franc nous
les passeront au crible à la fin du
journal ce sera notre dossier
bonsoir aujourd'hui déjeuner à l'ombre
du pétrole pour monsieur madame valérie
giscard d'estaing le président bongo les
recevait sur une plateforme de forage
sur la mer au coeur du gisement le plus
important du gabon puis monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing a quitté port gentil
pour franceville le président bongo il
possède sa résidence personnelle
l'accueil réservé au chef d'état
français tout au long de cette deuxième
journée a été aussi chaleureux que celui
de leur capitale libreville hier à sa
descente d'avion
valéry giscard d'estaing un style de
chefs d'état qui plaît aux gabonais le
journal de libreville le rappelait hier
matin les gens d'ici se sentent
facilement à l'aise avec ce jeune
gagnant
replié de plus partisan du dialogue
nord-sud entre pays nantis et pays en
voie de développement et la réception
organisée au président français a été
chaleureuse une réception à l'africaine
bien sûr avec tam tam et danses
populaires une ville pavoisée toute la
population sur les bord du chemin
emprunté par le cortège une foule qui a
le génie de l' enthousiasme et qui ne
s'étaient pas manifestés avec tant
d'entrain depuis la visite effectuée ici
par le président pompidou
c'est ce qu'on dit à libreville mais
tout au long de son séjour au gabon
valéry giscard d'estaing aura l'occasion
de mesurer l'évolution de l'état
d'esprit des dirigeants de ce pays pour
ce qui concerne les relations franco
gabonaises
certes la france demeure aux yeux du
président bongo le pays a mis par
excellence mais le gabon indépendant
depuis 16 ans souhaite aussi que la
coopération avec paris fasse peau neuve
la coopération du moins franco
africaines en général et franco
gabonaise est à notre sens ce n'est pas
un cap et redéfinit etc ou quand le
président de la république a besoin ne
sait si on donne quand on a besoin de
cela on demande au fait des acrobaties
au co
à mon avis je voudrais qu'il y est innée
cadre juridique que les gars vont sèche
que chaque année la france doit et ne
fut-ce que dans les domaines par exemple
de l'enseignement de la santé les dames
on doit donc d'uzège savoir que la
france doit lui donner tel tel et tel
tel nombre de coopérants maintenant
ainsi les nombres de coopération la
française met à notre disposition n'est
pas suffisant nous mêmes et gabonais
vont à l'écouté des coopérants français
repenser la coopération en tenant compte
du fait que le gabon entend tirer le
meilleur parti des richesses dont il
dispose ce n'est pas le moindre résultat
que les gabonais attendent de ce voyage
journée environnement pour le premier
ministre tout d'abord dans une note aux
préfets il donne ses instructions pour
protéger le littoral et respecter la
nature plus de constructions nouvelles
au bord de la mer mais à l'intérieur des
terres les nouvelles routes devront être
éloigné du rivage d'au moins deux
kilomètres c'est la mort des corniches
enfin les dunes et marais les forêts
doivent être respectés dans leur état
sauvage et protégée de l'urbanisation
voeu pieux ou réveille un peu tardif
ce sera le point de vue de paul lefèvre
enfin le premier ministre était à
castres aujourd'hui pour juger des
progrès de cette ville moyenne comme on
les appelle que cette ville devait
effectuer par contrat pour
l'amélioration de la qualité de la vie
au fond c'est plutôt réconfortant quand
on est un premier ministre seul à paris
et qui plus est investi de tous les
intérims ou presque un premier ministre
dont on dit tant de choses depuis tant
de semaines de se retrouver dans une
ville moyenne cité en exemple ville
amical qui est celle du député maire
jacques une musique au milieu d'une
population chaleureuse
loin des bruits de la capitale des
rumeurs et des intrigues jacques chirac
a profité pleinement de cette courte
visite qui lui a mis à coup sûr du baume
au coeur
il ne cache plus sa lassitude se voir
sans cesse désormais montrer du doigt
par la classe politique
jacques chirac nous avait d'ailleurs
prévenu il ne dirai pas un mot du
bouillonnement économico politique
actuelle n'a vraiment pas envie
d'alimenter la polémique
en revanche il est intarissable sur
l'environnement sur la défense du
littoral aussi nouveaux chevaux de
bataille du gouvernement continuer à
construire de façon systématique une
espèce de mur de béton le long des côtes
il est important maintenant de les
ménager de les sauvegarder
c'est un des éléments d'une politique
générale de l'environnement qui est
celle du gouvernement
est-ce que les villes moyennes monsieur
bré ministres sont pas succès et à ce
qu'elle contribue justement à lutter
contre ce que tout le monde appelle
maintenant les glissements de la france
les pendant longtemps on a laissé se
développer des villes beaucoup trop
important et on s'aperçoit actuellement
que c'est sans aucun doute allait dans
le sens contraire de la qualité de la
vie les difficultés de gestion des
villes importantes les contraintes qui
pèsent sur les habitants les conditions
de vie des citoyens ne sont plus
compatibles avec les exigences normales
naturel actuellement c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous voulons axer tout
notre effort sur le développement des
villes moyennes et leur meilleure
insertion dans le cadre dans lequel elle
dit elles sont c'est à dire dans
l'ensemble de la campagne qu'elles
doivent se développer et par conséquent
nous ferons en sorte de diminuer le
développement des villes importantes et
d'encourager systématiquement le
développement des villes moyennes et
ceci avec de préférence en habitat
individuel aussi dispersés que possible
et avec le respect des règles de
l'environnement donc par contraste avec
les rumeurs d'instabilité le premier
ministre ouvre et se définit dans deux
dossiers qui concrétise l'avenir ainsi
la politique de développement et dette
des villes moyennes et aussi ce texte
paru ce matin dans un logiciel sur la
protection du littoral
une liste d'instructions qui sont en
réalité le cadre d'une politique de
défense de la vie de l'homme et de la
nature qui l'entourent trois
orientations l'art et donc de la
construction anarchique sur le bord de
la mer ville résidence et camping un
encadrement sévère du réseau routier qui
ne doit plus saucissonné étrangler
l'accès au rivage et enfin la protection
par un classement quasi automatique des
zones naturelles c'est à dire les marées
les dunes la forêt les massifs et c est
évident que dans un texte de cette
nature et surtout de cette globalité si
vous permettez
certains vont trouver des
incompatibilités et peut-être même pour
être au fait l'atmosphère des sujets de
polémique
reste qu'on peut se demander pourquoi
maintenant et pour quoi faire
pourquoi maintenant ce qui est possible
aujourd'hui l'était hier
l'arsenal juridique est déjà bien
suffisant même s'il est perfectible et
des tranches de coder pan de montagne
des pièces de forêt ont disparu depuis
longtemps des sous des horreurs ou sous
des bénéfices
l'enseignement de ce qu'on ne peut plus
rattraper et qu'il faut sur v
et maîtriser la valse des dérogations
qui souvent de bonne foi n'ont pas -
ravagé ce qui était beau et à tous
pourquoi faire la construction de marina
de port nouveau l'implantation du sinn
d'ateliers de commerce d'un chalet ou de
résidence correspond bien souvent à des
besoins locaux qui font passer
l'esthétique après le développement ou
simplement la survie de la commune ou du
département cela il ne faut pas
l'oublier
ni le degli g s'il est urgent de
protéger les sites qui reste il est
honnête de savoir et de dire qu'il ne
suffira pas d'interdire la grève des
cheminots des agents de conduite de la
région de marseille et de celle de
montpellier largement suivi suivant les
dépôts 70 à 90% des conducteurs de train
sont grévistes
le service minimum prévu fonctionne
normalement la plupart des trains de
grandes lignes circulent la perturbation
du trafic ferroviaire doit atteindre son
maximum en ce moment-même vendredi soir
la reprise doit s'amorcer dès demain
samedi
le préavis de grève prend fin selon les
régions à minuit ce soir ou demain à 6
heures encore des morts en afrique du
sud de l'agitation continue à soweto
dans la proche banlieue noire de
johannesburg
les images des manifestations fait par
l' agence américaine disent nous ont été
censurés par conséquent personne ne les
a reçus la police sud africaine estime
que les affrontements ont fait deux
morts selon d'autres témoignages il y
aurait déjà huit victimes
c'est toujours l'état d' alerte à soweto
les étudiants se regroupent et pour le
chef de l'organisation de libération
sud-africaine les condition de la lutte
armée en afrique du sud sont réunis
rome aura un maire communiste on s'en
doutait depuis que le parti communiste
italien était devenue majoritaire aux
élections générales de juin dernier à
rome
la nuit dernière un accord a été conclu
entre communistes socialistes sociaux
démocrates et républicains sur un
programme municipal commun les deux mots
crac chrétiens ont préféré choisir
l'opposition après avoir tenu la
capitale de la chrétienté pendant une
trentaine d'années
le vote pour élire le prochain conseil
municipal est prévu pour le 9 août
prochain
ce conseil choisira un communiste pour
mr le retrait de ferrari pour les
dernières épreuves de formule 1 du
championnat du monde suscite beaucoup de
réactions ferrari renonce parce que son
premier pilote niki lauda est à
l'hôpital mais aussi parce que nous au
ferrari n'apprécie pas la réglementation
actuelle source d'incidents et de
contestation le gouvernement italien a
déjà interpellé que se passe-t-il ken
tyrrell le directeur de l'équipe
concurrente de ferrari d'éclat ce départ
est ridicule la ferrari est la meilleure
voiture actuellement un accident peut
arriver à tout le monde ferrari doit
revenir sur sa décision
l'accident de seveso inquiète les pays
européens déjà la commission de la cea
mise à la disposition des autorités
italiennes
une aide technique mais des médecins
ouest allemand accuse le gouvernement
italien d'avoir minimisé la plus grande
catastrophe par gaz du monde pour eux la
région de seveso devrait être interdite
pendant 15 ans enfin monsieur jacques
chirac lui aussi se préoccupe des
conséquences de cet accident il va se
renseigner et si l'on fabrique en france
du triple euros phénol ce gaz qui entre
dans la composition du gaz toxiques
eh bien il se propose d'interdire la
fabrication sage précaution
mais dans l'hypothèse d'un accident
semblable en france pourrait tomber ou
non guérir les personnes intoxiquées
docteur dali cette petite fille est
l'une des victimes de la dioxine
quelles sont ses marques je pense qu'il
s'agit effectivement de lésions de
dermatites aiguë tel qu'on en a décrit
avec le dioxyde en particulier chez des
ouvriers qui étaient employés à la
fabrication d'herbicides acquis pour des
produits d'où provient généralement la
dioxine
alors la dioxine est une impureté de
fabrication qui apparaît au cours de la
synthèse d'herbicides et en particulier
du 2 4 5t qui est un produit utilisé
pour débroussailler des foreurs et dans
l'état actuel des conditions de
fabrication des herbicides y at il en
france par exemple des dangers possibles
dans les conditions normales de
fabrication non parce que c'est un
problème qui en fait n'est pas récent
pour les
les spécialistes et actuellement il ya
des normes de fabrication qui sont
extrêmement sévères
aucun herbicide contenant plus d'une
partie pour 10 millions c'est à dire les
quantités extrêmement infime ne peut
normalement être mise dans le commerce
est ce qu'on connaît les conséquences
des tales émanation des jokes in alors
chez l'animal y ait des travaux assez
nombreux qui ont été faits on sait que
c'est un produit qui est cancérigène
pour l'animal qui provoque en
particulier des tumeurs du foie
on sait que c'est un produit qui et
tératogènes qui provenaient de des
anomalies de la face chez les
nouveau-nés et probablement aussi des
anomalies des reins par contre chez
l'homme évidemment les travaux sont bien
avancés de la seule référence que l'on
est
c'est ce qui s'est passé au vietnam les
médecins vietnamiens disque à la suite d
aurait fallu répondre massif qui a été
fait par les américains
la fréquence des cancers du foie a
triplé dans la population du nord
vietnam en dix ans et maintenant c'est
ont soigné alors le traitement
actuellement il est uniquement
symptomatiques on peut soigner les
conséquences de la dioxine peut penser
qu'il ya des recherches qui se
poursuivent actuellement pour essayer de
trouver ou un antidote
de décontamination plus rapide mais à ma
connaissance il n'y a rien dans ce
domaine qui sont actuellement
disponibles immédiatement
c'est déjà le temps du ballon rond et ce
soir à la fin des premières rencontres à
22h15 on recommencera à sculpter les
chances de l'om de l'ogcnice ou de nancy
de remporter le championnat
dans dix mois sans parler des verts bien
sûr qui cette année encore seront la
cible de tous de nouveauté cependant
dans ce championnat qui débute ce soir
tout d'abord la présence d'un treizième
homme sur le banc de touche comme cela
se fait en coupe d'europe
et puis et surtout la suppression du
bonus un bonus qui ne changeait rien au
niveau du classement puisque avec ou
sans le classement aurait été le même
ces deux dernières saisons
le spectacle y perdra peut-être mais
avoue que la logique sportive y trouvera
davantage son compte
reste que saint-etienne sera encore une
fois le favori de ce championnat avec
deux prétendant très sérieux nantes et
surtout nice qui présente cette année
une équipe très complète
alors que faut-il espérer au seuil de
cette nouvelle saison
un championnat très serré pour que le
football français ne soit pas le fait
d'une seule équipe mais aussi une bonne
participation de nos représentants en
coupe d'europe
nice sochaux marseille et saint-etienne
en souhaitant bien sûr à toutes ces
équipes l'amène merveilleuse aventure
que celle des stéphanois l'an passé le
visage à saint-etienne n'a pas changé
puisque en conservant le meilleur équipe
avec bien sûr des jeunes joueurs qui
avaient participé à quelques matches de
championnat la saison dernière et qui
avec une année de plus doivent jouer
plus souvent et notre objectif est
naturellement celui de la saison
dernière c'est à dire figurer parmi les
trois premiers du championnat pour
pouvoir discuter de l'uqo viennent
éventuellement la première place parce
que si ça nous permet de discuter là la
plus jolie coupe et détroit et puis je
pense que la préparation se déroule de
façon très normal il n'y a pas eu de
changement je crois que ce qui a été
fait jusqu'à présent a fait ses preuves
l'important c'est que les joueurs sur le
plan technique puisse se perfectionner
davantage voir un produit s'il faut
donner environ 2 francs français
même scénario pour le marquis pour avoir
un marc il faut donner environ 200
français aussi mauvaise fin de semaine
donc pour notre monnaie qui a perdu près
de 10% de sa valeur par rapport à la
monnaie allemande depuis le mois de mars
dernier
ce dérapage de notre monnaie cette
tension sur le franc comme disent les
experts
ce dérapage alex conséquences très
importantes sur votre portefeuille bien
sûr mais aussi sur l'économie française
en général
l'explication ce dérapage eh bien il
tient en un mot la spéculation fait le
dossier de notre journal
un commerce extérieur largement
améliorée un indice des prix en nette
baisse en juin - une performance dans un
budget pour 10 est en équilibre
on aurait pu raisonnablement penser que
notre monnaie commencerait à se
stabiliser sur le marché des changes
ici à la bourse de paris et pourtant
après une trêve en début de semaine la
spéculation s'en donnent à coeur joie
depuis deux jours avec en fond sonore
des bruits de remaniement ministériel
une ambiance faite pour les spéculateurs
mais au fait qu'est-ce qu'un spéculateur
tout le monde est un spéculateur le
directeur financier d'une entreprise
multinationale une entreprise qui a des
contrats avec l'étranger doit défendre
les contrats passés doit protéger la
maison d'éducation des monnaies quand
vous êtes expliqué que quelques grandes
entreprises puissent tenir votre normal
le sort d'une monnaie comme le france
bien coûter prenons le cas d'une société
d'importer de sport qui passent des
contrats à terme
si cette société
à exporter elle va avoir des rentrées de
devises étalée dans le temps à 3 mois 4
mois 6 mois si elle prévoit une hausse
sur ces devises n'a pas intérêt à les
vendre immédiatement sur le marché elles
attendent les rentrées réelle de ces
devises pour les vendre au contraire un
importateur qui a acheté du matériel à
l'étranger qui doit le régler dans les
mêmes délais trois mois qu'après six
mois a intérêt à acheter tout de suite
amené s'il prévoit que cette monnaie va
hausser et à ce moment là il ne fait que
défendre sa marge bénéficiaire la marge
bénéficiaire de l'entreprise qui a été
calculé au plus juste au moment d'un du
contrat il n'y a pas si longtemps
spéculation monétaire était synonyme de
dollars si la monnaie américaine
effectue à la bourse de paris ces temps
ci un spectaculaire rétablissement
près de cinq fois aujourd'hui elle a
pourtant laissé le devant de la scène à
une autre valeur le mark allemand
rien de plus normal à économie puissante
monnaie forte
le transit d'allemagne s'est il faut
bien le dire une monnaie fondante par
rapport à deutsche marks qui prend de
plus en plus d'envergure
la faiblesse du franc mais donc surtout
en évidence la puissance du deutsche
mark
en somme vu d'ici le franc est une sorte
de petit arbre qui souffrent de l'ombre
d'un grand chêne son voisin mais trêve
de symbole lefranc illustre surtout dans
sa faiblesse
la différence qui existe entre les
politiques économiques et sociales
allemande et française premièrement les
allemands lutte depuis plus longtemps et
beaucoup mieux contre l'inflation le
taux d'inflation avoisine les 5 %
outre-rhin
il est double en france deuxièmement la
vie intérieure allemande et marqué par
l'existence d'un consensus social dont
on ne peut que rêver à paris ici les
syndicats ont accepté de grignoter leur
pouvoir d'achat pourrait d helmut
schmidt dans sa politique de stabilité
résultat un coup de frein très sensible
à la course salaires prix troisièmement
la vocation de l'industrie allemande et
plus exportatrice que jamais l'allemagne
préfèrent vendre des biens d'équipement
plutôt que des biens de consommation et
autres produits agricoles sensible aux
aléas du marché international
ainsi malgré plusieurs évaluations
successives du marque depuis soixante
dix les allemands sont restés très fort
sur les marchés étrangers
sur ces bases l'allemagne est
actuellement le pays qui possède les
plus importantes réserves monétaires du
monde alors on pourrait croire que les
allemands se réjouissent de leur
stabilité de la santé de leur monnaie en
fait il n'en est rien la spéculation sur
la dot mac nous a jamais aidés la
spéculation de la donne sur la botte
smac a toujours fait importer
l'inflation que nous ne voulons pas
importer et comme pays exportateur nous
nous sommes intéressés à avoir des pays
clients qui sont en bonne santé qui sans
stabile sur le plan strictement
monétaire et annie avantage ni
inconvénient
parce que comme la france est pas dans
le serpent pour le moment les
déséquilibres entre des monnaies ça
arrange plus ou moins automatiquement
par le fait du corps flottant face à la
faiblesse du pont les allemands sont
donc loin de pavoiser
helmut schmidt
ne peut en effet se passer de
partenaires économiques forts ou du
moins st à cet égard la situation de
l'italie une offre suffisamment
d'occasions de prouver son sens de la
formule à l'emporte-pièce contre toutes
les apparences
les allemands ne tiennent pas avoir des
partenaires européens trop faible en
effet l'impression que donnerait
l'allemagne d'une trop grande puissance
par rapport à ses voisins gênerait la
république fédérale car l'allemagne de
l'après-guerre n'est pas encore un pays
tout à fait comme les autres
trente ans après 1945 mais il ya plus
concret à la tête d'un pays exportateurs
helmut schmidt sait parfaitement qu'il
ne peut se passer de ses clients et
voisins européens
il s'est aussi qu'un client sans devise
limite obligatoirement ses achats à
l'étranger et par contre aussi tenté de
fermer ses frontières aux produits
étrangers
et c'est là une hantise pour helmut
schmidt car cela signifierait pour lui
et son pays
des millions de chômeurs en attendant
seuls les touristes allemands en
vacances en france profitent de la
situation tout fait plus de 1 franc 81
pour un marc permet en effet aux
ouvriers allemands de s'offrir chez nous
des vacances de cadres moyens français
ce matin pour tous ces étrangers pressé
le des bureaux de change
la france est devenue un pays moins cher
l'essai mine soucieuse venait de
français qui ne possédait plus
aujourd'hui l'argent nécessaire pour
partir en vacances à l'étranger car
l'étranger est devenu plus cher
l'allemagne surtout les vacances de
septembre risque fort d'être plus
onéreuse que les vacances du mois d'août
jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas en
tant qu'organisateur de voyage ne m'ont
pas encore augmenter les prix mais nous
serons obligés d'augmenter les prix si
des différences de change se produisent
des différences importantes des
dévaluations dévaluation de fait comme
nous comme nous le vivons maintenant ou
et si des différences dans se produisent
des augmentations dans le prix de
transport hybride hôtel je voudrais
emporté de l'argent de poche en
allemagne est-ce qu'il faut que j'en
porte une somme plus importante que
prévu
indiscutablement bien sûr parce que bien
que même si vous vous n'allez pas en
espagne en italie en grèce dans les pays
que je viens de citer les dépenses
seront plus élevées du fait que le
français est plus faible et les vacances
de l'étranger ne concerne pas la france
entière les produits fabriqués à
l'extérieur est vendu en france
intéresse par contre tous les
consommateurs
et d'ici trois mois les hausses de prix
de ses produits étrangers risquent de se
multiplier
cet appareil de photo et allemand il
compte aujourd'hui 10 880 premier à
petit coudier à la fin de l'année bien
normalement il devrait supporter une
baisse de 10 % puisque le prix d'achat
de ces appareils va supporter une hausse
de 10%
cependant du fait qu'il existe une
réglementation qui ne permet pas
d'appliquer des hausses en valeur
proportionnelle au prix d'achat mais en
valeur uniquement absolue c'est dire la
marge bénéficiaire devant rester la même
quel que soit le prix d'achat la hausse
sera légèrement inférieure à la
dévaluation monétaire elle sera on peut
penser de l'ordre de 7 à 8 % avons bien
sur un court terme les conséquences
pratiques sont importantes mais à plus
longue échéance
il en est d'autres tout aussi grain on
peut sans doute pensé qu'un franc
déprécier nous permet de mieux vendre
nos produits à l'étranger mais il faut
aussi savoir que puisque nos
exportations vont par le même mécanisme
coûter plus cher
les bris français des produits
manufacturés qui intègre des matières
apporter vont eux aussi augmentent alors
que faire soutenir le franc sur le
marché des changes la banque de france
ne semble pas résolu pour l'instant à se
séparer de ses devises est de 100 ans
une dévaluation certains le souhaitent
d'autres lacroix inéluctable peut-être
mais là encore pas de mire à une monnaie
dévaluée ne règle pas tous les problèmes
d'une économie surtout en ce temps où
les affaires monétaires sont si
largement affaire de psychologie ou de
confiance arrivé aujourd'hui de la
première étape de la course en solitaire
de l'aurore et c'est guy cornou qui le
premier a poussé son voilier dans le
port de perros guirec cinquante et une
heure de course pierre pascoe est arrivé
deuxième à quatre minutes clare francis
veaute on attend vous est arrivé elle 6e
mais en fait cette première étape s'est
disputée comme une régate et c'est un
véritable sprint qui a départagé les 12
premiers qui ce matin étaient tous
groupés au passage de l'île de batz
ensuite et bien ensuite dans cette zone
escarpée il fallait se servir au mieux
des courants et geek hormis le vainqueur
de l'année dernière s'est mieux
débrouillé que les autres mais quatre
minutes d'avancé par beaucoup l'écart
l'année dernière était plus grands alors
espérons pour eux et bien que les vents
seront plus forts pour la deuxième étape
qui doit les mener en angleterre car du
vent aujourd'hui ben y en avait pas
beaucoup il faisait chaud et les
températures étaient surtout
en hausse sur le nord-est pour demain et
même pour dimanche le temps restera
chaud et ensoleillé quelques brumes le
matin de la manche haut rhin et très peu
de rage au voisinage des pyrénées la
rédaction d'antenne 2 se joint à moi
pour vous souhaiter une bonne soirée
et puis surtout une fin de semaine
reposantes mais agréable bon soir avant
de refermer ce journal parmi les titres
que nous avons développé ce qu'il faut
retenir
car au gabon dernier entretien demain à
libreville un plan pour le littoral
mieux vaut tard que jamais championnats
de france 1re journée
ce soir le franc jusqu'où descendra t-il
la dernière édition du journal ce soir à
22h35
m
hum hum